ground news is combating divisiveness in
media ground is a news comparison
platform that helps you see multiple
perspectives for any news story so you
can be more of a well-rounded news
reader download the free app at
ground.news
pacman you know the phrase sometimes a
little bit of knowledge is a dangerous
thing it really applies to a clip we're
going to look at today of lara trump
that's eric trump's wife donald trump's
daughter-in-law and now a fox news
contributor we're going to look at video
of lara trump saying she's against covet
precautions
because she gets really happy she's
thrilled when her children get sick now
the context of all of this is that
because of the explosive spread of the
virus again because of the delta variant
particularly among unvaccinated people
um places around the country are saying
masks are coming back on
some uh increasingly employers are
saying you're going to need to be
vaccinated in order to work here
remember that fox news has a set of
rules in place
where if you're not vaccinated and you
haven't proven your vaccination through
a portal that fox has which is like a
vaccine passport you have to keep
wearing masks when you work at fox news
etc so far this is happening on fox and
fox is doing a lot of this stuff
lara trump says a whole bunch of
different things that make no sense
whatsoever and that she's thrilled when
her children get sick so let's take a
look let's take a look vaccinated
americans fox news contributor laura
trump is here to react good morning
laura
good morning ainsley good morning i know
you have two school school-aged children
how do you feel about the children under
the age of 12 we'll have to wear a mask
again right
well i think it's absolutely ludicrous
first of all
we know the efficacy of masks have been
long disputed it was dr fauci who a year
and a half ago remember told us all if
it makes you feel better wear a mask but
remember
that was this is what how many months in
are we now 17 18 months in
for a couple weeks to prevent a run on
masks dr fauci and others did not come
out and say wear a mask then we learned
more and the the consensus among the
medical community has been mostly
unchanged for all but those first couple
of weeks we didn't have to wear a mask
originally he said it wasn't going to
really do anything oh come on then they
told us mass then they said three masks
they've gone back and forth on this but
as it relates to kids i mean i can tell
you it is almost impossible for my
three-year-old son to keep a mask on so
the idea that these kids are going to
have to sit through an entire day in a
classroom with masks on you see the
videos this has real i'd like to speak
to the manager vibes guys i have to tell
you the kids who are waiting for the bus
crying because they don't want to have
to wear the mask it gives them headaches
from a social perspective they can't see
the faces of the other children we know
also if we're following the science
things like we were supposed to do the
entire time that thank goodness children
do not get coveted in the same way that
adults do if they get it we know that
they get a very mild case of it they're
not the super spreaders they that we
originally were told they might be and
so the idea that we're going to make our
children sit in school massed up all day
long i think is absolutely ludicrous
they're also not coming in contact with
germs that they need to develop an
immune system my daughter carolina last
week had a cold every parent knows
that's a nightmare i have to tell you i
was so thrilled because i know that she
is actually getting in contact with
viruses and germs and bacteria that will
allow her to develop an immune system
this is absolutely insane that we are
considering so this is another person
who can't first of all can't understand
you might consider someone other than
just your kid because carolina trump or
whatever the kid's name is
it when it because it's thrilling to her
that her kid got a cold
um that's not a reason to say no masks
for kids at all even as this is
spreading uncontrollably and the issue
isn't kids building up their immune
system against the flu or against germs
the point here is to keep people from
getting covet 19 which is a deadly
infectious disease that can kill some
people it can land some people in the
hospital but even for people that it
doesn't make very sick they can pass it
and then infect others and possibly kill
others she doesn't seem to understand
that she can't think about anybody other
than maybe herself and her own immediate
family
which seems to run in the trump family
if you guys have noticed and by the way
you don't have to get sick to develop
immunity you know this idea that if
you're not getting sick you're not
developing immunity we have things
called vaccines which her kids will
hopefully soon be able to get even at
their ages if she'll go and get them
vaccinated and there is some truth very
broadly to the idea that you don't want
to keep your kids in a bubble if they
have zero exposure from the time their
kids to anything from a very young age
there are some studies that show that
that can be problematic that's not
what's been discussed here it's not
what's being discussed lara trump's kids
have been out in the world this entire
time up until the pandemic and wearing a
mask at school which by the way you
still get germs
on your hands and then later you're out
on the playground and there's dirt and
there's different things and you're
around don junior's kids and all this
different stuff just wearing the mask at
school for a few months is not going to
do whatever it is she thinks it's going
to do to their immune system it's
absolutely nuts but not as nuts as this
next clip
i have video for you today
of outrageous lunatic pastor rick wiles
who says he was made sick
by someone else's
vaccine
this is another guy who claims that
there were people shedding vaccine
around him
and it made him sick okay let's take a
look at this and it's i mean how does
this guy even get to work in the morning
we're witnessing for the first time in
human history global genocide whoa
compliments of the church of satan
the communist party is the political arm
of the church of satan
these people that are running the world
are are
safe in us they're
killing off
massive numbers of people tell me more
it's doing exactly what it was created
to do
and you know this was their plan all
along was to shame the unvaccinated
people into thinking that you're killing
these other people but really it's the
truth it's the vaccinated seem to be
carrying
whatever this bio weapon is that they're
unleashing on all of us i mean bio
weapon what when a whole year i shook 10
000 hands last year on the campaign
trail i didn't catch it didn't catch it
all last year wasn't until people
started getting vaccinated people
started getting really sick
so um and i'm convinced there we go
my infection and the the explosion that
we had here in our staff among my family
friends 20 some people all together
infected suddenly
i believe it came from a vaccinated
person coming into this building
who was shedding the virus
and i believe that's how it happened
that's the culprit a vaccinated person
now background on rick wiles this is the
guy who once said that the north korean
threat was caused by gay people he said
people are going to die because of gay
marriage he said that
some kind of numerology thing proves
barack obama killed supreme court
justice antonin scalia he said vegan
burgers are a satanic plot to destroy
the souls of people he said if trump is
removed there would be violence
um he well in a sen i mean listen trump
lost he wasn't removed and there was
violence but it was the trumpist he
warned of a jew coup to remove trump uh
and now he says that it was the
vaccinated person the one vaccinated
person that made everybody sick now as
i've said before there's no way to be
affected in any way by people around you
being vaccinated with the covet vaccines
used in the united states other than
you're less likely to die if people
around you are vaccinated if you are
sick with covid
your body can release particles of the
virus when you cough etc
if you are vaccinated with a vaccine
that contains live virus there is a
short period of time during which you
could be shedding the virus
none of the covet vaccines used in the
united states use live virus there is no
physiological mechanism for that to
happen with the covet vaccines in use in
the united states you can have viral
shedding after a vaccine if it is a live
virus vaccine the u.s is not using such
vaccines
and but it doesn't matter rick wiles
is he convinced is he just saying it i
don't know
but more dangerous anti-vaccine rhetoric
is there any good news well i think the
good news is more and more people have
been getting vaccinated for the last
couple weeks
the numbers got so low they are
increasing
that's a good thing and let's hope that
it continues
also let's hope that the david pakman
show continues past our 16th anniversary
the 16th anniversary coming up on monday
august 16th it's going to be an
incredible day and historic day
and we are also
deep discounting our website memberships
on that day we want to pull in a record
number of people i think the record for
single day new memberships is something
like five it's in the 500s and that
happened
quite quite some time ago
we want to do a single day record for
new members you can get on my mailing
list at davidpakman.com and then monday
morning you will be notified
i've been on fox news a couple of times
if i'm ever invited back ground news is
one of the first things i would use to
get my head in the game
and prepare myself for the interview
because ground news is a news source
comparison platform that lets you
compare how outlets from the left right
and center are reporting on a story it
makes it easy to see the nuances of how
sources with differing political biases
are covering a story and it also shows
you your news blind spots stories that
your side of the political spectrum may
not have covered ground news can help
you build a well-crafted argument for
debating people you disagree with or
ground news can help you discover
something new about your own perspective
challenging your own strongly held views
on political issues be the most informed
person in the room download the free
ground news app today by going to ground
dot news slash
pacman remember that the david pakman
show is made possible primarily by folks
like you who get memberships at
joinpakman.com i encourage you to do it
it just feels good i'm told by people
you can sign up and use the coupon code
better21 if you would like a discount no
reason that you have to have one but
certainly welcome to it
let's speak to some people
from the audience i want to hear from
the people we do this via discord you
can find the david pakman show discord
at davidpakman.com slash discord
why don't we start today
with uh faith from southern california
faith you were on the air
david can you hear me am i echoing i can
hear you find faith
all right wow it's so good to talk to
you likewise uh
my question is uh
so i'm kind of sick of the politicians
and it's been infrastructure week
forever yeah um
i kind of want to bypass all the
the
the stuff i'm a nursing home uh
administrator this pandemic has been
hell on us
and our kiddos
uh i say kiddos but anybody who is
disabled and in a nursing home
um
has very little resources and they've
been stuck inside and isolated
unfortunately
and um
volcano someone who's been on your show
and who you've spoken to
is about is
has
has called me and
i have an infrastructure proposal and i
wanted to see what your thoughts on it
are
here in southern california we have 116
community colleges all of them have
child care on campus and it's great for
students the community and um it's great
for a building job
experience for this for students on
campus if we could build
adult day care on campuses
that would be something that is such a
big
need
uh to be filled
is that something you've ever heard of
um
but i love the idea and it's similar to
the idea of
postal banking let's create the op the
the possibility of banking at the post
office so that people who were unbanked
or maybe live in places where there's a
post office but no bank would have
readier access to banking services i
love that type of idea of thinking
outside the box in that way i don't know
exactly how it gets carried out and
jurisdictionally and from a regulatory
standpoint there's complications but yes
faith a very good idea
thank you and so we're trying to push it
uh with uh for the
national infrastructure week because
it's been infrastructure week forever
yeah so if you you people with
disabilities in mind you're a great
advocate i love your show if you could
continue to advocate for people with
disabilities and their family they're so
isolated and it sucks because they're
the people with the biggest hearts and
if if i find that in california we have
these community colleges with childcare
on campus if we can get adult dependent
care on campus
i imagine that on a national scale this
community would be so much more
supported and less isolated creating
jobs and creating opportunity all right
thank you very much i appreciate the
suggestion thank you very much there is
faith with really a great idea
uh it's a it's a very very interesting
idea
let's go uh next to toby from kansas
toby you're on the air
hello can you hear me yes i can
hi david uh i called about a month ago
and i had an uber call me in the middle
of our call that i had to dash out so i
just want to apologize for that um my
question is surrounding
the uh the conversation you had with
destiny about uh student loan
cancellation i was wondering what your
uh like final position was are you more
of a
you do want universal cancellation or
are you looking for more of a
uh bottom-up approach wait
my sam cedar recently had a conversation
with destiny about that which
conversation of mine are you referring
to oh i i was referring to your post uh
discussion i i i think you guys had a
quick like sum up didn't you and you
guys were talking about whether it
should be oh i don't think we talked i
don't think we talked about that at all
no i've talked before i i'm not
understanding the case for full student
loan cancellation period flat out um it
the impact of it is not clear to me
would actually be progressive and i'm
not sure what the justification is just
for saying
pay everybody's debt period altogether
so no i but no i didn't talk about that
with destiny after that i did talk to
destiny recently after his sam cedar
thing but we didn't really talk about
the student loan stuff now toby i have
to ask are you originally from kansas
uh no i actually moved to about eight
years ago uh from the uk ah that's
making sense yeah no because you didn't
i i mean i've only been to kansas once
but i didn't hear people with your
accent there
no definitely not um i'm in the i'm in a
college town so it's a lot less a lot
more left-leaning than the rest of uh
kansas but i see it's definitely uh
definitely definitely different than the
uk that's for sure that's for sure all
right toby thank you i appreciate the
call
um i did have one more thing i just
wanted to say is your family uh back in
argentina happy for lionel messi for
winning the cup of america or is he like
some other argentinians as i understand
that they kind of prioritize maradona's
success no everybody in my family is
very pleased with uh with messi's
victory yeah
all right well that brings joyce my hot
and i hope you have a wonderful day
thank you very much i appreciate that
yeah big victory in the copa america for
argentina it was an incredible it was an
historic day i think i would uh i would
even venture to say
let's go next to bobby from savannah is
that savannah georgia bobby
uh yeah it is actually that's great yes
i can
okay um
well i just want to get quick as i have
to go to work soon it's a real simple
question because i know you've been
talking to your audience about
incentives to get people who are vaccine
hesitant to get vaccinated right and i i
noticed i i even saw this on
twitter
i think new york city they're actually
going to give a hundred dollars
to people who get vaccinated i i don't
understand why we can't just do
a
thousand dollars from the federal
government if you get vaccinated or a
thousand seems like a lot i don't know
that a thou i don't know the math of it
a hundred is it a hundred dollars cash
or a hundred dollar tax credit
um
anyway
any tax credit i think the one in new
york is a just they're gonna give
whoever gets vaccinated 100 on the spot
wow i could be wrong i just saw that but
i don't understand why we aren't just
paying people to get vaccinated at this
point yeah i haven't um i haven't heard
about the new york thing but i think
financial incentives would be fine you
know for people who say oh we can't
afford that listen we can we can
actually figure out um for a given
unvaccinated population
what is the likelihood of
hospitalization death all of the
associated costs including productivity
loss and loss of tax you could figure
out and you could be like okay for the
average ten thousand person population
we expect to spend x amount of money
divide that by ten thousand let's just
give that to people and then you that
you i think that the math would favor
something like that if my instinct is a
thousand dollars is not the number maybe
it's a hundred but that's very
interesting if that's what's being done
yeah i mean
my main thing about the thousand dollars
is i'm just basing it off like the
stimulus checks but regardless like the
amount if we go under lockdown again
we're going to have like trillions of
economic productivity absolutely so
and like i i don't think even all these
people who
will position and virtue signal about
like not wanting to take the vaccine i i
don't think they'll put up those excuses
if they have the option to get a
thousand dollars that may be that might
be i mean i think the other thing you
have to remember also bobby is that
there's lots of states that are never
going back into lockdown no matter what
so so it's also you know they that make
for better or worse but they're states
that have made it clear no matter what
happens we're not putting any any
guidelines back on
i mean if i feel like if another strain
comes out that the vaccine doesn't work
i mean i'm a medical student and my
understanding is that there's delta
variants coming yeah it's more
infectious but there could always be
some sort of mutation in the spike
protein that
is not like associated with the vaccine
and then it can avoid the actual
um
target yeah there could be a
vaccine-evading variant delta is here 90
of us cases now i believe are delta and
you're right that it's relatively well
handled by the vaccine yeah of course
those states could change but i like the
idea do a tax credit or cash on the spot
when people complete a vaccination dose
why not
yeah i and plus i i think especially now
i i do think there's still probably
issues regarding
um unemployment stuff like that people
still need money there
there are part portions of this nation
like i'm from the south everything's
back up but i know in other parts of the
country there's a little bit more got
more guidelines and more restrictions
that are leading to
whether it be workers business owners
not having enough um
access to
just demand overall access to demand
yeah i mean listen things are uh that's
a different that's a different thing for
the most part businesses or businesses
are open things are open and and so on
and so forth but um things are going to
get very ugly if we don't get more
people vaccinated so i appreciate you
bringing it up
okay thanks all right thanks so much
appreciate that there's bobby from
savannah
we have folks not only from all over the
country
but quite frankly from all over the
world who are hoping to chat with me
today i'm going to do my best to speak
to at least a few of them let's speak
next to gabriel from colorado gabriel
you're on the air
hi can you hear me yes i can
okay um so this is not so much a
question but i do think it is important
for people to hear
um about a month ago
uh let's say a month and a half ago um
my father who is a
you know a very loyal fox news viewer
tucker charleston fan
um contracted page of 19. and uh
61 healthy active
hit
um
two weeks and he passed away in bed um
so i just thought oh my god gabriel i'm
so sorry to hear that gabriel that's
absolutely horrifying
yeah thank you um so it's been a little
rough but
i want to
at least take the opportunity to make a
a lesson out of it a story for people to
hear to understand that
it i mean it could
it can hit close i can hit anybody it's
you may think your family members may
think that they are safe yep because i
thought he was safe because he took you
know supplements and he exercised and
he uh
it just took him out wow is it has
everybody else seen it as a wake-up call
if people were unvaccinated to get
vaccinated
as far as i can tell at least within the
family
for the most part people
are understanding the severity of this
yeah my mom
she tested positive for antibodies and
she's uh they were separated but she's
similarly in the same sort of
skeptic
perspective
um
so she's not getting vaccinated but at
least she has antibodies from a previous
effector so you so your your mom is
aware that your dad died of this and she
still doesn't want to get vaccinated
yes he actually sends me a lot of reads
like aww sort of
um
these all these aren't like underground
articles about
this you know this health expert speaks
out i guess so whatever and what not
about how terribly dangerous the
covenants are wow
wow yeah uh well gabriel i i'm so sorry
to hear that and uh
if anything i hope that somebody will
hear this and it'll be a cautionary tale
and they'll go and get themselves
vaccinated
yeah that's what i hope yeah thank you
all right be well my friend
oh okay take care wow i mean like this
and that's
that's what it is right i mean that's
the uh
that's the story that's the story we
keep hearing time and time again uh
let's go
next to
um
why don't we speak to
thomas from massachusetts thomas you're
on the air
what's up can you hear me yes i can
all right
so first of all i hear you're from mass
as well so hello from a fellow
massachusetts uh citizen yeah i grew up
in massachusetts i'm actually from
argentina now in new york but i'm
intimately familiar with massachusetts
um so my question is usually during
midterms the incumbent political party
loses seats yes and as like we know even
with a slim majority republicans are
already bottlenecking legislation so my
main concern is making sure we win the
house and senate in the midterms
so hold on a second
i'm con i'm not even sure that so wait
with a slim major
dem republicans don't have a sl the
republicans are in the minority now
and democrats control the house and
senate are you saying you want democrats
to retain control in the fall i just
want to make sure we're on the same page
as to what the situation is right now
yeah i was more referring to the senate
how like only kamala harris is giving us
the advantage i want more control got it
got it got it
so i was thinking do you think we should
go like the milk toe center left route
of just trying to unify everyone or take
the more progressive left stance to get
more people no taking taking the milktoa
center left approach won't unify
everyone i think that that's the mistake
it's not it will it will lead to
the the the center and the right we'll
call center-left extreme leftism
and then
the progressive and further left we'll
call center-left republicanism
and i think it's just that there's no
evidence whatsoever that doing that is
actually going to help anybody on the
left
yeah i was a very pro go more left so i
just wanted to get your verification on
that yeah no i would i mean i think what
makes sense is
you figure out what the national
platform is going to be and then you
figure out how to win races in the
different states in which you're running
and it may be different to win a race in
florida than to win a race in washington
state as a democrat and i think it's
okay to run the races differently in
different states
okay got it well that's all i had so all
right thanks thomas
appreciate it thank you very much
let's take a very quick break
and then if you're holding don't hang up
because i'm going to go right back to
the phones in just a second
don't forget that the best way to
support the david pakman show is by
becoming a member which gives you access
to the daily bonus show the regular show
with no commercials you also get access
to our entire archive of every episode
dating back
a really long time and plenty of other
awesome membership perks go to
joinpackman.com
and use the coupon code better21 for a
huge discount
join pacman.com
okay let's hear from a few more people
people in the audience people like you
you can talk to me through the david
pakman show discord which you can find
at davidpakman.com
go next to adam from philadelphia adam
you're on the air
uh hey i just wanted to say thanks but
um
can you hear me a lot on queerto yes i
got
um with uh republican parents like mine
who are completely
against the vaccine and kova and all
and versus
someone who hang on
um they are not letting me take it at
all and i'm only 17 and
and my mom's reasons are not political i
know that but my dads are they are fox
viewers every now and then they
they are complete yeah they're complete
republicans and all they don't trust the
science and all that they're though
but
what is your message to those teenagers
out there who
are not allowed to get the vaccine so to
be clear you're saying you're not your
parents won't allow you to get the
vaccine is that right
that is correct okay the first thing is
in some states you don't need your
parents to allow you to get it when
you're 17. have you first explored what
the the law is in your state
no i have not okay so the first thing to
know is in many states when you're 17
you can just go and get the vaccine they
don't you don't need your parents to do
anything so if you were to decide that
that's something you want to do if it's
legal you could investigate whether
that's a possibility does that make
sense
yeah okay second part is how far from
being 18 are you
six months okay five months so at the
most in five months you can get the
vaccine right i mean no matter what even
if you can't get it today because of the
the you need parental permission in five
months you can get it so what i would
say is
wear a mask and be careful until that
time
i mean you know your parents better than
i do
it it sounds like it's a lost cause
trying to convince them right like
you're not going to be able to convince
them
yeah my mom um she she's actually more
like afraid of it i should say like i
think that's what you need to like we
need to understand is like why sometimes
they're not gonna be taking it is
because of like my mom always tells it's
the it's just the style of it and
my dad says oh but you know j and j
that's that's not really what modern and
pfizers are doing at all but my mom's
always saying though but there's all
these reports about j j coming out about
you know these these heart problems and
stuff that's all they talk about
yeah i mean you know listen again the
question is does it make sense to argue
with your parents and say the risk of
covet is much greater than the risk of
the heart thing
um but i just don't know because you
might be able to go get vaccinated now
depending on the law in your state or in
five months you can i just don't know if
it's worth fighting with them i just i
don't know
yeah i never tried doing that because
again i know what they really do believe
in if i if i really try to tell them the
truth and all they they are really they
are really third against it let me ask
you this adam
is your mom
less against it than your dad
um
i don't think so i think she's not
really against i think she's again more
skeptical of it she's a skeptic but what
i'm saying is if there was one parent
who would be more okay with you getting
the vaccine would it be your mom or your
dad
probably my dad yeah okay so maybe when
your mom's not around you go to your dad
and you say dad listen
i need to be protected
i need to go and get the vaccine will
you come with me so that i can get it
and just see what he says
okay i mean i don't know and again you
might be you this might be moot because
17 year olds in your state might be able
to just go get vaccinated you might not
need your parents permission
yeah that i have to look into it then
check it out all right adam let us know
how it turns out okay
okay all right thank you yeah that's
that's tough i mean we get a lot of
calls like that
it's uh
it's it's pretty wacky pretty wacky
why don't we go next to john from philly
john you're on the air
hey good afternoon how are you dave hey
this is john from the dr right living in
philly yes how are you remember i
remember you i remember you
how are you i'm doing well
very well very well so my question is um
what is the deal with the
um
with this democratic uh
whose i call it the
without this project the
infrastructure beer that they trying to
push are you talking about chuck schumer
i'm not sure who you mean
i'm not the the you know yeah in the
senate they they tried to push the
infrastructure beer and
they never success in anything i i
guarantee to you yeah that
if the republicans were in control of
the house the senate and the white house
they would push the very immediately oh
of course oh my goodness john if
republicans were in the situation
democrats are in right now
uh everything would be done they'd have
passed tax reform they would just
hey what is the deal with the democrats
holding off the beer i don't understand
that well holding up i mean part of the
problem john is no the democrats aren't
even on the same page about what they
want to pass you have people like joe
manchin and kirsten cinema who don't
want the same things that bernie sanders
wants and because they have of the
slimmest possible majority nothing gets
done that's what's going on
yeah but
i i'm going back again to the same thing
yeah like you're okay republican may
block the beer or something but
you know they control the white house
you know yeah
you know maybe binding can push it we
are you know
we all support anybody you know i'm
saying they aren't controlling my house
i agree and listen john if joe biden
doesn't get something major done with
democrats and what's left of this
calendar year
i think democrats get crushed in next
year's midterm elections
i i guarantee that that is going to
happen yeah i guarantee because they
don't you know they're waiting for
nothing yep
there's no what are they doing it makes
i i completely agree with you john it
doesn't make no sense waiting for
nothing
you're you're absolutely right well
let's see let's see if they get anything
done
all right davey both uh nice talking to
you you have a wonderful day sir you too
there's john from philly uh great to
hear from him as always
why don't we go next to vincent from los
angeles what's going on in la these days
vincent
oh um
nothing
nothing much i haven't been outside in a
while personally it's good to get some
of that vitamin d you know
yeah yeah um
i i wanted to call in and ask basically
like
i listen to your show a lot and it's an
honor to speak to you pleasure
um
a lot of things outside is really like
i don't know listening to a lot of
what's going on with the sort of purging
of the republican party and
um
gets me and you know what's going on
with climate and covid gets me really uh
nervous i was wondering if you could
maybe talk about things that have been
going on that might give you uh
like hope as to uh you know things
getting better in the world yeah i mean
listen it's like if you
what might be useful for you and maybe
others is sign up for a good news
newsletter there are a lot of these
which just tell you about good things
that have gone on you look at how long
are people living on average after being
diagnosed with all types of cancer
survivability has gone up you look at
you know the you can find positive
things that are going on look at the
increase the continued increased
efficiency of solar panels for example
or
look at the way in which many countries
have shifted more and more towards
alternative energy you can definitely
find that stuff but it's also a reality
that there's a lot of really bad things
going on right now i think it's
important to kind of
see both you know
yeah now i'm curious when you say you're
you're not you're not not going out
because you're depressed about all these
things that are going on and you're just
staying home right are the two things
you mentioned they're separate issues
um to some extent to some extent oh are
you like kind of depressed and just not
leaving your house
uh just dealing with some social anxiety
i don't know like one of the greatest
things that's caused me fear is like uh
in particular like the fear of uh
nuclear you know weaponry around the
world and that's making you stay home in
some sense
yeah yeah i mean i don't know how much i
want to
talk about it but yeah wow i mean on a
very practical level do you think you're
safer from nuclear fallout at home
rather than you know down the street at
a cafe because it seems either way if
there's nuclear fallout
you just might be screwed i don't know i
don't know that i would worry that much
about it in that way
that's that's a very good point
i guess i'm just thinking like if
there's a if there's a nuke that's going
to be dropped
i'd almost rather be at the basketball
court or at the pond rather than in my
house because either way it's going to
be bad and i have no control over it
that's my thought you know
yeah yeah it's understandable yeah try
to get out there maybe take a 10-minute
walk today you know
yeah you know i think i'll go ahead and
do that i like now and i'll take a look
at uh some of the things you mentioned
as to positive signs let's do it james
let's do it and i want to hear from you
again okay let me know how it goes
okay thank you very much great talking
we got to get out there that's sad that
makes me sad we really you know
staying at home in order to avoid the
bomb i mean uh
i'd rather be having a cappuccino you
know i think that's the that's the
situation for me all right why don't we
speak next to
um let's speak to let's go international
let's speak to carl
from
stockholm carl from stockholm are you on
are you unmuted can you hear me
um
all right that's too bad i was hoping to
speak to carl
let's go to schizo from north carolina
you're on the air
hey can you hear me yes i can
awesome uh pleasure to speak to you i
found your show not too long ago
um
i have a couple questions okay i
have been dealing with
sorry i'm kind of a little nervous but
i've been dealing with uh my fiance who
is
buying into all of these conspiracies
that are going around
and basically
she has
put an ultimatum in
the relationship she's basically said
that if i get vaccinated it would be the
end of our relationship
and
it's
it's really stressing me out because
i'm constantly
like researching and finding that the
the claims of conspiracy theorists don't
hold water that's right when you
actually
do the research that's correct yeah
so i
but the problem is
i've seen her go from
being completely afraid of this when it
first started and then
attaching
to these conspiracies
as a way to cope with
the fear yep that she was having that's
very common that's very common people
would rather take solace in the the
conspiracy which suggests that we have
much more control over things than we
actually have it's scary that this might
be an out of control pandemic so folks
would rather believe whatever conspiracy
theory about the virus or the vaccine
that's very common
yeah
the the the problem i'm finding myself
in is
because i
i i haven't gotten vaccinated yet and i
i really do want to because i have
basically i have a one-year-old child
and
i'm not willing to take the risk that i
won't be here for him
and uh that makes a lot of sense
but
for her it's not that for her it's it
seems that if i do so it's almost like a
religious belief where it offends her
that it will be the end of our
relationship
and basically it's boiled down to if i
do this i am
uh a stupid person for falling into this
this whole thing so i do you have any
recommendations like well that's right i
can't tell so let me ask a couple
questions is this is this the the mother
of the one-year-old you just mentioned
yes it is okay um and uh how long have
you been together
uh about three three years now and do
you do you want to continue together
yes absolutely i'm well i'm willing to
to
to stick around because i i also am
afraid of the issues that will happen
if i'm no longer in the relationship and
what she'll do in order to keep me away
from my son
that's a scary thing that's a scary let
me listen i'm gonna i'm gonna i don't
know the full situation and ultimately
you have to decide but let me ask you
this have you thought about just getting
vaccinated and not telling her and not
talking about it yes yes that has been
my conclusion this past day or two i
actually talked to a friend and he's
like listen this i know it sucks but
maybe that's just the thing to do the
only so i've i figured that that's
probably the best option for me
um
but now i've thought
of what am i going to do when i get my
vaccination card
because we're going to be going to
we're going to be going out of town soon
and
there's i find my i think i try to think
ahead and will that will there be a
situation where
we we aren't going to be allowed to do
something unless we have we show our
vaccination card and
you know i'm going to be vaccinated but
she's not and
well listen i mean basically you would
just if you want to keep it secret you
would just have to be like if there's a
she's not going to be allowed to do that
thing anyway
so then maybe you're just both not doing
that thing and you don't need to worry
about it just just go out you'll you'll
be vaccinated but you can go out and do
your unvaccinated life with her i mean i
i agree that it sucks but if the
priority is you think it could be a
really bad situation for your child and
so you wanna i i i it's really hard for
me to give serious you know to seriously
give advice because i don't know the
full situation but my immediate mind
goes to at least get yourself vaccinated
and just don't mention it so that you
are less likely to get the virus and
spread it to her
i i
that's kind of what i've come to there's
only just one question i have left and
it's
i i want to get vaccinated but i want to
uh
not
give it away that i'm vaccinated by
having any side effects so
i i don't know what you recommend oh you
just say you're feeling under the
weather i mean the the side effects you
would have would be sort of like feeling
a little bit cold or flu-like so you
just say
i've i'm a little i've got a cold you
know
okay yeah you said you got vaccinated
did you get the which one did you get i
got moderna
oh sorry cut off i can't hear you i got
moderna
okay
all right skit so sounds complicated
sounds like um we're having a connection
issue so i'm gonna let you go but that's
that's a tough situation that's a tough
situation all right guys i've taken all
the calls i can take today we will take
calls again very soon
if you value what we do at the david
pakman show remember to support us on
patreon go to patreon.com david pakman
show where you can get access to behind
the scenes videos the daily bonus show
the commercial free daily show as well
as special discounts on merch including
hats hoodies mugs and t-shirts you can
support the show for as little as two
dollars a month
check it out at patreon.com david pakman
show okay let's get into audience
questions first one very timely very
important david the federal eviction
moratorium
is ending soon what is going to happen
when all of these people get evicted in
the next few months well that's that's
not going to happen actually i think
it's important to let's contextualize it
yes i believe july 31st is actually the
day that the federal eviction moratorium
that's coveted related will will come to
an end
but there's a bunch of different reasons
which explain why you are not going to
see nearly even a majority of the people
currently in theory in in
at risk of getting evicted get evicted
dean baker the economist talked to us
about this last last week he said the
number being bandied about is about 8
million people could get evicted but
that he believes in reality it will be
more like eight hundred thousand and as
he said it doesn't mean we don't care
about the eight hundred thousand
but eight hundred thousand evictions
uh nationally
is not necessarily going to be a major
economic disaster doesn't mean we don't
care about the people doesn't mean we we
don't need to fix the situation so
there's a few different things that you
have to remember
first of all depending on what state or
even city you live in
the fact that the federal moratorium
guidance from the cdc ends on july 31st
doesn't necessarily impact you because
there are states and in some cases even
cities that are choosing different dates
so there are already some states with
moratoria
or moratoriums colloquially
that are in place that will go longer
and two of the states or some of the
states with the largest populations like
california texas and new york
have protections that go beyond july
31st already both for residential as
well as for business evictions you've
got other states like illinois oregon
hawaii
new jersey washington new mexico they
have um their own guidelines in place
that go longer than july 31st
texas has local um eviction moratorium
that has been um extended to i believe
it's october 1st or maybe october 31st
so
the there's the idea
that on a single day all these people
are going to get evicted the reality is
many states have already extended that
the other reality and this doesn't help
people
it's just from an economic shock
perspective it's important
it takes a long time to evict people and
it takes a different amount of time in
different municipalities it can take
months and months to evict people
i know
various lawyers that work on evictions
both with tenants and with landlords
often it's the same lawyers that work
with both not in the same case but work
with both they say depending on the
state you could take three to even six
months depending on if it's a place
where it gets cold in the winter there
are even bigger restrictions in place
all the time so there's not going to be
a single day of evictions now one
additional factor here
california and new york
have announced programs
where they are going to pay past due
rent for a lot of people who are at risk
of getting evicted so in those places
when the moratoriums finally do end
there aren't going to be mass evictions
because the states have put in place
these programs so
for me the bigger question is the
following
so many people live paycheck to paycheck
you miss
one paycheck
you miss a payment for your rent you can
essentially never catch up there's an
emergency you've got a health insurance
plan with a 2 000 deductible and
something happens where you've got to
pay the 2 000 all at once and so you
miss a rent payment
you essentially can never catch up
and that is a bigger reality that
whatever you feel about paying past due
rent like california for example put in
place doing even if you feel like that's
the right thing to do or whatever um
even getting a lot of people out of the
current situation imagine someone who's
behind on rent because of the pandemic
lost their job now they're kind of
keeping up but they're not able to catch
up
um
they're going to end up statistically
anyway some percentage of them are going
to end up back in that situation anyway
because so many people are living
paycheck to paycheck that's not going to
change even with rent forgiveness
the last thought on this there are
people who say
that because real estate prices have
become so overblown in many parts of the
country
that an eviction and even a foreclosure
crisis
would be a really good thing it would
pull down prices
and um that is not necessarily wrong in
some states but there's a question as to
whether we should
hope for
the misery and stress and anxiety of
being evicted
as a path towards a modest reduction in
housing prices which may or may not even
be permanent so that's kind of a bigger
discussion but that's the bottom line on
evictions they're not going to happen
all at once not that many are actually
going to take place and you've got to
really pay attention to what's happening
in your state and in your municipality
in particular
david is it likely that if trump runs in
24 he will be unopposed in the
republican primary no
trump if he runs in 24 trump will almost
certainly be opposed the question is
whether it will be a serious challenger
we could if we were to imagine what is
the most serious challenge that donald
trump could face
one school of thought would be
somebody like mitt romney runs an
anti-trump republican with some name
recognition
i don't know that romney gets more than
10 or maybe 15 in a republican primary i
think the way things are right now trump
owns the republican party trump crushes
basically whoever tries to run against
him the one name
that seems to have more power against
trump
would be ron desantis who is essentially
a a more competent trump which is
extraordinarily dangerous even desantis
seems to have only low 20s i think in a
couple of recent straw polls it was
something like 21 22 support or
something like that so at this point in
time this nomination is trump's for the
taking if he wants it if he wants it i
don't think anybody else is going to be
able to mount a successful challenge you
know people talk about what about lisa
murkowski or something
no i just don't see it i just don't see
the name recognition i just don't see
the interest level so to speak in
supporting her over trump when trump is
sort of the de facto and as of as of
today still widely supported by the
republican party i think that trump's
perspective on this let me go back
when i was on michael cohen's podcast a
couple of weeks ago michael cohen said
he doesn't think ultimately that donald
trump runs
and he had a number of different reasons
that he gave we uploaded that to our
youtube channel and you can check that
out if you want to hear more about that
but one of the arguments about why trump
ultimately won't run
is trump is able to raise money and
benefit from
kind of alluding to running and doing
events and asking people to donate to
the save america pack or whatever but
not actually saying i'm running and
maybe never actually running the idea
being raise as much money as he can get
as much attention as possible paralyze
the party so the party can't say okay
he's not running but they also can't say
he is running as for as long as trump is
doing speeches and talking about i think
you'll like what we decide
but not announcing a candidacy he
paralyzes the republican party he keeps
people under his thumb and that's
exactly what donald trump wants to do
and he can just keep grifting his
supporters new report he raised you know
who knows tens of millions of dollars
over the last six months claiming it's
all to fight the election results he has
spent no money on fighting the election
results because the election was nine
months ago and nothing is going to
change
but that's what trump wants to do he
wants to keep raising money so i also
see that even if trump is not ultimately
going to run
it's very much to his advantage to
pretend that he is
my instinct is
if he's healthy and 2022 goes okay for
the trump wing of the party trump runs
that's my opinion only michael cohen
said i think he he doesn't run in the
end and ego was a factor and a few other
things
we will just have to wait and see
but the best case scenario
um for trump would be
that this co if he is ultimately going
to run that keeping this situation in
limbo
prevents the republican party from
really getting behind anybody else in
particular it prevents other people from
really building support because trump
still has the majority of the electorate
supporting him
and then you know he says i'm running if
that's indeed what he's going to do and
he doesn't even give oxygen to a
possible uh serious primary challenge
the other thing would be
what if trump runs third party
i don't even really want to get into
that right now because i
see it as very very unlikely but if
you're if the scenario you think is the
most likely is trump runs third party i
would love to hear from you
hey david why don't republicans focus on
policy instead of culture war issues
wouldn't it be better for them
electorally
i don't know that it would be
and the reason that i say that is
it's not clear to me
that republicans actually have the
support to win on the issues
if repub what what was it that donald
trump did
that prior republicans didn't do that
essentially gave trump the victory in
2016. it was that he ran a campaign
based on cultural issues
and personal attacks
and fears about communism socialism
hillary etc
where
his voters didn't actually have to
evaluate policy and say does the policy
actually
sound good to me
some examples where the republican party
if they were to run on policy would have
a problem
um abortion is still used to raise a lot
of money by republican candidates but
the truth is that the american public is
more in favor of abortion being legal in
most cases than it has at any time in
the roe v wade era so if republicans
really made abortion a bigger issue it
might not be so good for them uh if you
look at the republican perspective on
taxation when you really get down to it
i've said a lot of bad things about the
populist movement and how they can
bamboozle people
but one of the things that
the more populist republican base has
gone towards
is
to be more hostile to tax plans that are
just good for rich people now trump
still passed one that is mostly that but
because policy was so secondary and the
cultural issues were more important
trump was able to achieve an electorate
that really doesn't care very much what
his policy is most of the things he
promised he was never going to be able
to do and it didn't even matter no one
actually held him accountable and
ultimately what brought trump down was
his mishandling of the coveted pandemic
i maintained that if the coveted
pandemic hadn't happened
and
because trump mishandled it right
there's the idea well trump could have
handled it well and won yeah trump was
not going to handle it well if trump
didn't end up having to mishandle kovid
he almost certainly would have been
reelected and to me when you say why
doesn't the republican party run on
policy it seems to me it's actually
better for them electorally to run on
these cultural issues we're against
critical race theory nobody can even
define it these people barely know what
it is
but it gets so much oxygen think about
the coverage of critical race theory on
fox news over the last three to four
months and then think of how it fires up
the base and it spreads i mean these
memes spread like wildfire
money is raised i'm coming out in
opposition of critical race theory in
schools donate to me imagine if the
entire time it had been about like tax
policy
they would not have gotten the attention
that they did and so to me it actually
seems you know same thing with we're
against communism and socialism joe
biden's making us a communist nation you
ask these people what is communism they
have no idea
and this allows them to continue moving
forward without ever really having to be
accountable for bad policy by just not
talking about policy i actually am
increasingly of the mindset that
republicans do better right now
by talking about the cultural issues
than they do uh by actually switching
over to policy check out my segment from
earlier this week
whether a culture war is even winnable
because that's another factor that the
left has to consider but i don't think
that
i think it's
disgusting in terms of the debasement of
american political discussion that
there's one party that doesn't even
pretend to care about policy that's
really bad for the country
but i think it's probably in a sense
the better choice for the republican
party in terms of winning elections
because they have a constituency
that wants to just fight and yell and
scream and cheer about cultural issues
and they don't really want to deal with
policy in any serious way that's why
trump won in 2016 were not for covid he
would have won in 2020 as well
send me your thoughts if you disagree
with me i do want to hear from you we
have a great bonus show for you today
sign up at
joinpacman.com get instant access and we
will see you then
thanks a lot for watching today's show i
just want to take a second to tell you
about today's sponsors ground news is
combating divisiveness in media ground
is a news comparison platform that helps
you see multiple perspectives for any
news story so you can be more of a
well-rounded news reader download the
free app at ground.news
pacman